bone squints were known for being pretty
open-minded about new people and
experiences that is until they weren't
keep watching for the bone scene that
makes us uncomfortable for all the wrong
reasons
one of the best things about bones is
the even-handed accepting nature of the
jeffersonian staff when confronted with
lifestyles they've not previously
considered it makes sense that
temperance brennan would keep an open
mind when thrust into a new culture
brennan is a forensic anthropologist but
you don't get to that profession without
studying some cultural anthropology
along the way she knew a lot more about
other cultures than her colleagues and
she wasn't afraid of shoving that fact
into people's faces she was a smart
confident woman who didn't pipe down
making her one of the strongest female
protagonists to come out of television
in the 21st century fbi agent booth on
the other hand usually has a more
reactionary view of the things he's
seeing but to his credit he didn't feel
put down when temperance knew more than
him he accepted it as a fact but these
two viewpoints still frequently came in
conflict with the show eventually coming
down in bones favor most of the time but
one time the show just completely
whiffed it season 4's episode titled the
girl in the mask is wild to behold after
years of gender discourse in the episode
a japanese forensics expert dr haru
tanaka travels to dc to help booth
investigate a death dr tanaka dresses
very androgynously and the squints
obsess over what their quote real gender
is so any guesses we don't really have
enough evidence yet no not the case
a doctor
dude or dude
the scene that goes too far lands near
the end of the episode fed up with not
knowing angela hugs dr tanaka until they
have a biological reaction to being so
close to a beautiful woman angela thus
concludes that dr tanaka is a man not
only is this extremely invasive but the
team ignores the possibility that dr
tanaka could be a gender or non-binary
nobody just asks dr tanaka what their
pronouns are which would be the polite
thing to do brennan does an excellent
job of never gendering dr tanaka always
referring to them by their full name to
obviate the need for gendered pronouns
at all the misgendering of dr tanaka has
its roots in orientalism the episode
scores some points when sweet says dr
tanaka belongs to the k subculture which
is known for its genderless style and
that tanaka's gender shouldn't matter
however the rest of the team essentially
dismisses dr tanaka's gender expression
as a japanese thing but plenty of people
all over the world identify as
non-binary and what could have been an
excellent opportunity for representation
on tv just ended up being problematic
and disrespectful the girl in the mask
only came out in 2009 which isn't that
long ago yet it manages to ultimately
damage androgynous representation on
screen by insisting upon the
significance of assigning everyone a
binary gender role in an interview after
the episode came out ali maki who
portrays tanaka spoke about how that
division emphasizes a clear cultural
divide between western and eastern
sensibilities maki discusses how she was
at first hesitant to audition as well as
how the creative team lowered her voice
register in post-production she also
provides a different type of insight
into the character and how strangely the
episode actually confronts western
culture's ideas on gender maki explains
i thought it was hilarious that the
three characters wanted to know man or
woman man or woman it was so important
to them maki who is japanese american
goes on to clarify how japan is far more
accepting of androgynous identities that
don't neatly fit into binaries she goes
on to state in japan you know it's like
no one would really care you're walking
down the street and it wouldn't even be
an issue whether the episode succeeded
in getting that idea across is open to
interpretation but it's clear japan has
been ahead of the curve when it comes to
accepting individuals of all gender
identities few would argue the episode
could have done more to be more
inclusive of non-binary identities
perhaps by casting a non-binary actor in
the role while television still has a
long way to go with greater lgbtq plus
representation we're in a much better
place today than we were even 10 years
ago check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite modern classic
series are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]